[Music]
I'm here in Killians workshop in
Hollywood and that this is Killian and
you have been training people for a
number of years yes in the art the craft
of commercial work yes I've been doing
it for about nine years teaching people
how to book commercials and how to
audition properly I feel I could learn
yes and I feel in a way my late night
career has helped me back on my
commercial work what I'd like to do now
is on the weekends I have kids and a
wife but you know there's friction there
and I like to get away so maybe on the
weekends I could book commercials yeah
exactly
yeah let's just see one and see what you
do what's your name my name is Conan
O'Brien and okay I have a question about
seafood about shrimp if you say 21
shrimp is it 21 shrimp or 21 shrimps I
got a no cuz this is great tasting
dinner deal going on right down at the
International House of Pancakes
delicious deep sea dinner deal and what
am I going decide to have the fish and
shrimp deal do I say fish and shrimp or
fish and shrimp not great that agree you
agree I'd agree alright
it wasn't bad bad Wow okay I thought I
said it didn't feel great and I thought
you were gonna say don't be crazy that
was great that's correct I'm not saying
that okay be honest with me yes wrong
well it wasn't that there was anything
wrong per se it only could say wrong it
just wasn't right you don't have saying
so like you actually looked up wrong in
the dictionary it says not right but my
legs
okay not really what today I'm like I'm
like a cat that's ready to pounce
see now they recorded that now the
client here's that client just heard
that I'm in an incredibly eager coiled
feline that's okay I'm gonna bind the
client hearing I'm gonna cut at this
moment I'm gonna recently okay what's
your name Catherine's ready to spring
kana Brian I've got this question about
seafood about shrimp if you say 21
shrimp is it 21 shrimp or 21 shrimps I
gotta know cuz this is great tasting
dinner deal going on right now the
International House of Pancakes pancakes
they say they'll have a strip deal
die-cut what too much hands what's wrong
with me using my hands I'm not saying
the robot guy right but if you take that
energy and bring it into your body ready
yeah you're gonna do a turn in as
anytime yeah I'm gonna do a turn we can
try that we don't really do that in
commercial audition let's see what
happens for you
you know what we'll do one thing make
one suggestions details start start
trying stuff okay
I have a question about seafood shrimp
if I say 21 shrimp is a 21-2 number 21
shrimps I got to know because there's
this great tasting dinner going on right
now the International House of Pancakes
and I need to know I was trying to go
fast I saw to make room and applause
that I took how'd that work well you
know how it works so you're asking how
that work is it dick move that didn't go
well please help me okay so now let's
get to work
what is really going on in the scene
someone's wondering is it shrimp or
shrink that's right and why why is this
important in his life at this I guess
ease it has a neurological disorder
obsessive-compulsive or it's such a
great deal he doesn't want to get it
wrong does that work with you oh I like
the or does it use it a lot just saying
the or emphasizes other points of view
he could be all those negative things or
it's annoying okay question about
seafood and shrimp if you say 21 shrimp
is it 21 shrimp or 21 shrimps I got a no
because there's this greatest tasting
dinner going on International House of
Pancakes a delicious deep-sea dinner
deal with 21 succulent shrimp or is it
shrimps whichever they also have another
tasty deal a fish and shrimp dinner with
luscious fish and lots of shrimp toward
shrimps pain getting worse looks like
going to try to have the fish and shrimp
deal do I say fish and shrimp dark fish
and shrimps can't satisfy my wife or
hold a job
you know my name you're moving on to the
next phase which is Paul this is called
the bite and smile okay so you bite into
it and you smile yes okay and the line
is wow Greg this burgers amazing
Wow Greg Greg Greg is whoever you want
it to be in the scene okay but not my
mail lover
well you can have any back story you'd
like someone who just recently
discovered he was gay realized he was
gay and now I'm with Greg and he's
completely changed my life and he just
made me this burger and I'm biting into
it and it stands for a lot hi topa Greg
yes in a sense last night I took a bite
of Greg and today I'm thinking it
shouldn't matter what my relationship is
Greg is it really shouldn't in life it
shouldn't no no I agree with you
yeah actually okay action and drags my
lover okay when you tell the audience
what's happening that's called
indicating but that lets them know
exactly what's going on I never took an
acting class but I think it'd be do a
mark hello let's forgive it when I'm
watching a movie I will I I would
appreciate if a guy character came out
and said hello I'm evil well well well
that would help
they don't do that they don't do that
enough because it's called indicating
yeah because most people can figure out
who the evil one is and that's part of
the fun and mystery of going to the
movie when you use your turn signals you
avoid an accident okay now I'm a new man
have not called the wife yet so wearing
your wedding ring I noticed that but I'm
going to call her
there's no I'm with Greg Greg actually I
look great hmm it's a really great
burger Greg but we want to have the eyes
up we didn't really see the eyes as you
bit they were they were closed I'll try
and open my eyes okay
it's not me it's the client so the
client while German said yeah
[Music]
if the camera can't see your eyes the
camera can't see the story right the
eyes tell the story have none
no one's secure you've got nice eyes I
have beady little creep there's another
rat right now look you know okay let's
do this again great burger
Greg do you mind if I I brought on a few
hats and that might help
Greg's partner maybe just rank his
partner they ride around in a squad car
together and that's where we ended sex
last night let's try it okay action
[Applause]
glad you my lover okay clearly I'm gonna
get yes so far commercials are huge
they're moneymakers for actors teach me
how to get a car okay so I'm going to
narrate from behind camera the scenarios
okay then you're going to them okay and
action and then you're driving along and
driving along and all of a sudden these
storm clouds show up but it's like
Katrina rain and they're driving along
and driving along and all of a sudden
this this newspaper flies in your
windshield you look nervous when all
these storms are happening yeah yeah so
you said Katrina right you said
Katrina's coming that's right and you
don't want me to look nervous
so what kind of car you driving a car
that no hurricane even the strongest
hurricane recorded in the last 50 years
can disturb this car that's right that's
not amazing this car because the real
what we're really selling is not a car
we're selling safety insecure I see okay
so so no matter what happened yes so
right now I'm driving the Ford delusion
I can sermonette we're driving along and
driving along and now it's like green
but it's Katrina REE
that's good Trina you're driving along
and driving along now bike messenger
hits your car you're in the delusion no
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you're saying I hit a guy on a
bike but because I'm in such a nice
luxury car I don't give a [ __ ] crazy
this car is making me immoral man on a
bike struck my moving car during
Hurricane Katrina and you want me to be
like feel that leather human beings must
be eradicated so we're driving along
driving along and all of a sudden this
bike messenger hits your car
[Applause]
hi hi hey Allison how are you okay why
don't we start with the jewelry one is
that okay let's get the couch tell me
your name is hi and you are sir I think
we know funny Brian just try to make it
as real as you can it's just kind of a
heartfelt moment and action I've got
something for you
it's in this box let's make this an
incredible year this was expensive and
it costs a lot of money yeah it's
beautiful
yeah we should thank you so much we
should have
go ahead maybe think those thoughts in
your head but don't please set yeah I
got something for you
yes let's make this an incredible year
love it
well I hope so when you told me one
pointed it out
I'm very passive-aggressive would you
use any of that you know I thought the
beginning was really good I want to do
it one more time cuz honestly the yeah I
think you're really feeling it but it
honestly read a little creepy
a little bit this is not the first time
I've heard this I got something for you
let's make this an incredible year it's
really
[Applause]
berry and look the and he kind of looked
into the camera and made like the smile
that says amazing jewelry right I
totally appreciate the choice they were
making I'm just saying I can tell by the
fact that you're putting down my choice
I just you know I'm hoping that you get
that story commercial
[Music]
[Applause]